et j'ai déposé un amendement et visant à
supprimer ces annuler à 3 et 4 dans la
droite ligne de l'amendement que j'avais
déposé hier sur l'article préliminaire
c'est pour que nous puissions parler et
du régime de capitalisation ça n'est pas
obsessionnel mais je crois que dans une
loi de finance de la sécurité sociale on
peut difficilement éviter de parler de
ce sujet
supprimer ce régime spécifique de la
Banque de France moi je pense que c'est
une erreur c'est une erreur d'abord
parce que c'est un régime qui est calé
sur le régime général on prend sa
retraite à 62 ans comme le font un grand
nombre de Français c'est un régime qui
est un régime de capitalisation et nous
sommes un certain nombre à penser que le
régime de capitalisation est moins
fragile que le régime de répartition
pour les raisons de démographie que l'on
connaît dont on a suffisamment parlé
c'est un régime qui verse au Trésor
public un excédent et ils sont pas si
nombreux que cela en France il verse au
Trésor public un excellent et c'est un
régime qui ne demande rien au
contribuable alors supprimer ce régime
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez curieux à une époque où on se
pose la question de l'équilibre de nos
comptes
sociaux
j'observe que si on avait géré de la
même manière la retraite des
fonctionnaires avec le même dispositif
le budget de la France ferait une
économie de l'ordre de 50 milliards et
puis enfin comme parfois il faut faire
un peu de politique mais c'est un régime
qui nous permet de constater ce qui est
une véritable conversion de la gauche
jamais jamais je n'aurais entendu madame
linman défendre avec qu'au temps de
conviction un régime de capitalisation
jamais mon excellent collègue président
Bocquet je n'aurais vu défendre avec
autant de vigueur un régime de
capitalisation président Laurent vous
avez eu des mots extraordinaires pour
défendre la capitalisation tout cela
sous l'autorité du président rénal
décidément il se passe quelque chose cet
après-midi au Sénat d'Asset exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]